ça va te monde passe un bon moment et
n'a qu'un des enfants dans la salle de
traoré hockey parce que moi ma plus
grande peur c'est de faire des enfants
je sais pas comment je vais les élever
la semaine dernière on a gardé mon neveu
de 15 ans enfin bon c'est un ado typique
1 sur sa peau beaucoup de stars sur
sedar beaucoup de blagues sur sa tête
goudjil dans sa tête beaucoup de vide
pas grand chose le gamin est à plus rien
qu'il a l'air moyenne générale 6 ennemis
ni les soeurs ya aucune meuf qui veut
lui il est sûre il lui reste un pur sang
de batterie il n'est pas bien namassa
compliqué oui tu m'étonnes qu'ils
appliquent batterie toute la journée sur
son téléphone comme un débile tu as et
en plus elle touche veille dans sa
chambre il est pas bien le gars qu'est
ce qui t'arrive question qu'est ce
qu'elle avait à 9
elle a posté une photo d'eux s'est fait
sur instagram paulo et dégoûté parce que
tout le monde a vu son cul est non je
suis dégoûté parce qu'elle affecte deux
lacs ça veut dire quoi c'est face à sion
tout plat tracé histoire un décompte de
la génération comme un train qui est
flippant surtout si les réseaux sociaux
en fait parce que les gamins ils sont
influençables hockey et ça allait
marquer l'ont bien compris c'est pour ça
qu'il ya un nouveau métier qui s'est
créée qui s'appelle influenceurs est ce
que vous connaissez les influenceurs
alors un influenceur pour ceux qui ne
connaissent pas généralement c'est un
mec dont le seul fait d'armes sait qu'il
a fait une émission de télé réalité
alors celle que vous voulez les anges
secret story les marseillais versus la
conjugaison peu importe
et ça se multiplient comme des petits
pains ce truc maintenant en a pour tous
dans tous les domaines influenceurs mode
flanc ce reboot et influenceurs cuisine
bientôt ça va être quoi les flics est
vraiment bête chez toi bonsoir monsieur
contrôle de police c'est du fitr
vous êtes un dealer attendant moi je
suis un influenceur drogue
le problème de cette génération c'est
les exemples qu'ils ont une des filles
les plus suivis par la jeunesse c'est
kylie jenner
oui c'est qu'ils kylie jenner c'est la
petite soeur de kim kardashian rituels
et kim kardashian ils en sortent tous
les ans un peu comme les iphone il
rajoute 2 3 aux tur et puis ça passe et
elle est suivie par plus de 120 millions
de gens sur les réseaux pour vous dire
la puissance de la meuf
un jour elle a twitté snapshots et pas
ouf dans la journée leurs actions à la
perdu 6% et ils ont perdu plus d'un
milliard de dollars donc kylie jenner si
tu pouvais faire un petit tweet le sans
plomb 95 s'est pas perso moi ça
m'arrangerait ça arrangerait pas mal de
monde dans le pays
le problème c'est cesser de la vraie
question c'est quel monde on va laisser
à nos gammes et surtout quelle planète
on va leur laisser parce qu'on est en
train totalement la bougie en fait ce qu
ils sont ils sont formels les
scientifiques qu'ils ont des on dit si
on continue comme ça dans à peu près 92
ans by aura plus d'humains sur la terre
pour 92 en rendez compte ça peut
paraître beaucoup mais 92 ans s'est pas
beaucoup en 92 ans c'est quoi ces ses 23
coupe du monde
ces huit pape c'est un mandat de
bouteflika c'est pas grand-chose 92 ans
les gars ça va très vite
le problème c'est qu'on le sait tous les
mois le premier et on est tous sur un
toit viendront pas la priorité annoncée
c'est quoi la question qui a été le plus
posé en france sur google en 2018
pourquoi maître gims port des lunettes
c'est ça la question la plus posée
tu peux demander ce que tu veux google
est ce que les français veulent sort
c'est pourquoi le groupe porte des
lunettes
alors que la vraie question en fait on
devrait tous se poser c'est pourquoi
maître gims voilà pourquoi maître gims
ça suffisait déjà comme question
c'est dommage parce que on est vraiment
une civilisation de ouf je mens on a
fait des trucs de dingue
là on avait trouvé de l'eau sur mars car
elles ont séparé les visons -trudeau /
mars la nasa
ils sont même en train de voir si
pourquoi pas un jour on pourrait pas
vivre à long terme sur mars est la
première chose qu'ils ont demandée alors
chercheur c'est de voir si on pouvait
faire pousser des vignes qui un jour il
y ait des vignobles sur mars a donc le
premier critère pour qu'une planète et
ce aux habitats c est ce qu on peut
prendre l'apéro quoi c'est pas le truc
c'est vrai que c'est quand même une
époque formidable aujourd'hui que les
smartphones les applications à tout à
portée de main ni limite était même plus
besoin de bouger de chez toi resto ciné
c'est terminé netflix des libéraux les
suppositoires pourquoi faire que de
prendre un truc dans les faits si elle
prélèvement à la source maintenant les
gars est l affaire en direct comme une
lettre à la poste
trêve de plaisanterie faut qu'on se
bouge tous le cul et qu'on fasse quelque
chose et le vrai enjeu c'est comment on
va construire le monde d'aujourd'hui
faut arrêter de parler du monde de
demain si on fait rien aujourd'hui
demain ça sera trop tard tu es c'est un
peu comme ceux qui font des régimes et
qui se met à faire du sport fin juillet
en pensant qu'ils auront un corps de
rêve sur la plage au mois d'août c'est
trop tard mon je voulais
ressembler à beckham tu ressemblera
juste un kebab voilà pour moi le corps
génération france 98 champion du monde
de black blanc beur on était intouchable
puis à partir de 2000 les maires des ont
commencé à arriver
la montée du fn les attentats nabila
camping paradis on va s'arrêter avec
c'est en fait le problème c'est qu'on
bluesy la planète parce qu'on consomme
tous beaucoup trop ah c'est ça le
problème
ils ont dit que l'année dernière le jour
du dépassement c'était le 1er août se
dire qu'à partir du 1er août
on avait déjà consommé tout ce qu'on
devait consommer sur l'année ils ont
même dit qu'en france on consomme
tellement que même si on avait toute la
planète que pour nous les français
elle serait trop petit et imagine toi
une planète que deux français qu'à
l'étranger
enfin comment les racistes est vraiment
galère mètres avant que c'est sur mon
frère frère fouet par un petit arabes
unis ont fait plus il ya peu c'est fini
ça j'ai déjeuné avec ce tueur
c'est du pénal auquel il va dire que
c'est pas en arabe mais ça de la barre
ça se bagarre c'est l'émission qui file
façon notre planète et les plus du tout
attractive c'est plus du tout sexy on
l'a tellement dégueulasse et que plus
personne
je pense qu'on n'aura jamais d'invasion
extraterrestre et entre nous je pense
que c'est pas plus mal qui viennent pas
les extraterrestres parce qu'on arrive
en riant nous observons je pense qu'ils
se poserait pas mal de questions tu vois
et pourquoi ils font tous les rires les
gueules pourquoi ils détruisent la
nature
et puis surtout pourquoi maître gims
porte toujours des lunettes elle est
très étrange cette planète
moi j'ai une théorie sur le fait qu'on
avancera sept mois par exemple j'utilise
que 10 % de mon sort de 10% attendue
pour cent et tous les jours je suis
serein avec ça mais comment tu expliques
que je suis serein avec 10% de cerveau
qui en panique avec 10% de batterie
c'est pas normal tu vois il ya quand
même un élément qui est plus utile dans
la vie que l'auditoire sam et moi mais
moi je suis à 10% rien c'est une moyenne
on est à 10 % c'est à 10% tout crois-tu
il faut dix personnes pour ça fasse un
cerveau c'est une équipe de foot un
cerveau ils sont 11 fautes mais si le
11e c'est franck ribéry mais participe
il contribue pas globalement faut qu'on
arrête de nous laisser le champ être
écolo ça devrait pas être achevée on
devrait nous l'imposé parce que vous je
sais pas mais moi perso dès que j'ai un
choix à faire
je fais le mauvais clairement ces
regards des lattes et un moment j'avais
six chefs ça se passait bien des fois je
regardais art est carrément un jour ils
m'ont mis la tnt ben j'ai fini regarder
de mec à poil sur nrj quand l'homme il a
trop le choix il finit forcément par
faire n'importe quoi tu as déjà vu la
gueule de ton assiette quand tu vas dans
un buffet à volonté
sushi merguez île flottante sauce
barbecue tu te respecte plus juste passé
c'est gratos surtout m pour qu'on fait
ça et si tu veux vraiment concernés par
la cause écologique il faut me faire de
la publicité
moi je suis un peu bête c'est je réagis
casse à tous le slogan elle est racoleur
pucheu à fond dedans par exemple des
pics je fais du vélo
qu'est-ce que je pécho
avec le tri sélectif tout les mêmes
motifs depuis que j'économise
électricité c'est par la tête du moins
c'est que sa triplette voilà ça
m'intéresse j'ai envie de savoir comment
fait du goût et bien sûr l'homme au
dernier réagit qu'aux slogans et ya des
marques elles sont encore plus subtil
que ça c'est pas que dans le slogan
elles vont te mentir c'est qu'on vont
pas tout te dire
mcdonald's slogan venez comme vous êtes
ce slogan complet venez comme vous êtes
repartent avec le diabète jeu subtil les
gars bien sûr était un des problèmes
c'est que on se sent investie que pour
les choses qui nous concernent la vie ça
ne concerne pas directement ça c'est
ainsi par exemple aux infos tentant
limitations de vitesse les routes passe
à 80 je vais faire une manif et je me
mobilise
si par contre tu entends disparition de
l'espèce les pandas passe à 80 je vais
faire une raclette je suis emballé oui
je suis pas un tendre à toi faut qu'on
se mobilise vraiment tous tu vois il
faut que l'état y donnent l'exemple
parce que c'est bien beau de dire à toi
qu'il faut être écolo mais la vérité
c'est qu'un tiers de la pollution
mondiale
c'est les usines chinoises qui fait
tourner les usines chinoises et en
grande majorité les pays occidentaux
font rater de nous prendre pour des cons
non c'est non seulement l'état il fait
n'importe quoi mais il veut qu'on porte
le chapeau si tu te fais baiser mais qui
doit s'en tire toi coupable c'est comme
si tu te fais voler ton scooter avec la
semaine d'après le voleur et tapait les
10 euros mais consomme ta merde en fait
mme et apparente 48 secondes seulement à
la draft gt gt poser chez moi devant
devant bfm tv il parlait de ses la
grande catastrophe
tu vois décathlon qui met en vente en
voile tu sais pas vous mentir je t'ai
choqué sur amont sur le culte ya encore
des gens qui vont chez décathlon puis
d'un sérieusement mais il sait qui c'est
jean sérieusement la planète est en
train de cramer et toi qu'on peut parler
d'un bout de tissu faut respecter les
priorités et entre deux mois je la
planète je la trouve assez patiente avec
nous parce qu'on est tous en train de la
détruire
cela nous laisse faire tranquille alors
qu'elle pourra régler le problème en
deux secondes c'est un petit tsunami une
crotte de nez ya plus personne
1 je sais pas pour vous mais l'homme est
très faible c'est la nature pat est déjà
sortie de reconnaître deux centimètres
de neige
c'est plus pareil c'est game of thrones
le truc ça crie ça pleure ya dénoncé un
autre délire j'te dis et malgré tout ça
faut rester positif
nous on y croit vraiment on se dit qu'on
peut renverser la vapeur c'est que si on
fait tous un petit peu mais on pourra
peut-être faire de grandes choses c'est
ce qu'il disait confucius
c'est là-bas d'éclat 5% de batteries
quand tu suces il disait si tu veut
déplacer des montagnes commence par
déplacer de petites pierres c'est beau
c'est profond et il a même terminé son
discours est un peu qu'ils le savent en
disant si tu t'accroches et que tu ne
baisse pas les bras
peut-être qu'un jour enfin au fond de
toi tu seras pourquoi maître gims porte
des lunettes
voilà la question la plus importante
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]